it's Fan Appreciation Month it's screen
junkies and to reward our awesome fans
we're making the honest trailers that
you voted for here's your number for
choice from meathead comes a satire of
all those sappy swashbuckling medieval
love stories that happens to be the best
sappy swashbuckling medieval love story
ever made the Princess Bride
dive into the film that every kid is
guaranteed to love with the title that
every boy is guaranteed to hate in this
real movie about a mate a book based on
a real book about the same made-up book
that the real movie it's based on wait
is that right
gather round for a tale of epic romance
that kicks off a young boy's puberty is
this a kissing book nice kissing again
you don't want to hear that I don't mind
so much as the world's grumpiest grandpa
read you a story
full of beautiful heroes dashing rogues
and cunning villains who probably sound
a lot less impressive when their words
are coming out of Peter Fulks mouth
Ashley and I are joined by the bonds of
love that's just true love you think
this happens every day cuddle up for a
story about the power of true love
between Wesley the farm boy turned
pirate and Buttercup the farm owning
orphan turned princess when fate
conspires to keep them apart nothing
will stop true love from bringing them
back together whether it's kidnapping my
Wesley will always come for me death
death cannot stop true love the fact
that he's kind of abusive that was a
warning highness
the fact that she's kind of a pain fond
boy polish my horse's saddle want to see
my face shining in it by mourning the
fact that he's an optimist and she's a
pessimist it's not that bad
or the fact that they haven't spoken in
five years and the relationship was
based on him doing chores for her until
things got extra spicy farm boy fetch me
that picture
[Music]
yep looks like true love to me but
there's more than just romance prepare
for plenty of action to go around really
really polite action purpose I don't
have to miss you'll foot Daniel Rock now
for time I sordin will try and kill each
other like civilized people where no
danger is too great that you can't carry
on a polite conversation
you are wonderful thank you come sir and
no enemy is too vile that you can't have
a nice chat while they're trying to kill
you lies to not become us well-spoken
sir truly you have a dizzying intellect
I guess this is exciting so settle in
one more time for the action romance
comedy drama kids movie for adults that
you probably never saw in theaters but
re watched on VHS so many times that you
can quote every line not just because
it's great but because every character
repeats their little catchphrase like a
hundred times as you wish story
Zorro Pirate's Booty hi my name is what
my name is who my name is ticky ticky
inigo montoya obey danny de vida SHhhh
small wonder his fingers go to eleven
crabby sets cheesy music
and obvious stunt doubles but come on
who cares this movie's amazing adventure
time why don't they make satirical
fairytales anymore with romance and
action and jokes and a big giant guy oh
right
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers thanks to fans Anthony M grace
B and Tiffany l for requesting this
movie and adding to the awesomeness of
fan appreciation month we always do as
you wish
need more click the box in the lab to
watch the fifth place pan Choice on his
trailer Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure
and click the box in the right to enjoy
an interview with Jay AV ona director of
a monster calls and the upcoming
Jurassic world 2 as he reveals how he
made Liam Neeson into a monster tree
aren't you a little short for a
stormtrooper why you stuck-up
half-witted scruffy-looking nerf-herder
good morning good morning it's great to
stay up late inconceivable hello my name
is Inigo Montoya you killed my father
prepare to die have fun storming the
castle